what's going on guys today i'm going to
explain every abnormal titan that's made
an appearance in the attack on titan
anime over the years we've seen how tons
come in many different shapes and sizes
and while it would be easy to assume
that all the freaky looking ones must be
abnormal that's definitely not always
the case whereas normal pure titans can
be expected to walk a certain way and
eat whoever's in front of them abnormals
will deviate from one or both of those
characteristics for example they might
purposefully walk past one person so
they can eat someone else instead or
they might do crazy stuff like climbing
up trees jumping like a madman or hyping
themselves up as they go into battle
as we'll see in the video there are
other things that make them different
but the point is that a titan doesn't
need to have a weird face or look like a
character from breaking bad to be
abnormal but rather their behavior and
the way they move with the main factors
from this point on i'll be explaining
the different abnormals that have made
their marks on attack on titan but
before we get into it don't forget to
sub if you haven't already as i plan to
gradually explain everything worth
knowing about this series
also i want to thank selfshock for
sponsoring this video which should be
the go to vpn for any of you looking to
protect your online privacy whether it
be hackers advertisers or even the
government there's always someone these
days who wants to track our online
movements but searchlock secures your
data by encrypting all information sent
between your devices and the internet
they do such a good job that searcher
was recently rated as the best vpn for
security by pc mag and what makes this
even better is that it's the only major
vpn that you can install on unlimited
devices for just one subscription i've
personally been using the app on both my
phone and laptop for over four months
now and besides protecting my data
wherever i am the interface in general
is just really smooth and easy to
understand for a limited time by going
to search dot deal slash turtle quirk
you can get a mind blowing 83 off a two
year plan plus three months extra for
free which in simple terms means the
subscription will work out to just two
dollars and 21 cents a month
understandably this deal is only
available for a very limited time so
click the link in the description and
use code total quirk if you want a cheap
way to protect your online privacy today
okay so in no particular order the first
abnormal in this video is often referred
to as the talking titan but its weird
behavior goes way beyond the fact that
it can speak to this day there are
certain things that only this pure titan
has been shown to do including mourning
the death of someone it killed running
away from people instead of running
towards them and trying its hardest to
fight against his titan instincts
initially this abnormal was introduced
in a special one-off chapter written by
isaiah himself which was then later
adapted and expanded upon during an ova
however in order to fully explain this
titan we need to flashback even further
than this
around 60 years before the start of the
series yamir was a false prophet living
in mali who was worshipped by a group of
loyal followers those followers believed
she was a descendant of royal blood and
among them was this woman who would one
day become the talking titan once the
group was discovered by the marlin
authorities everyone involved was sent
to paris island and this lady was seen
directly next to emir before they were
turned into pure titans in the manga we
saw the result of their transformations
with the talking titan crawling besides
the emir titan and following this moment
they presumably went their separate ways
flash forward decades later and this
abnormal was just chilling in the woods
when it encountered a member of the
survey corps who was stranded in titan
territory without a horse by pure
coincidence this particular scout had a
strong physical resemblance to ymir even
down to the freckles and because of this
the talking titan mistakenly believed it
was ymir herself that's why rather than
immediately trying to eat her like a
normal titan would the abnormal spent
time heavily breathing collecting its
thoughts and eventually speaking the
first words to come at its mouth were
subject of ymir which in hindsight was a
massive hint as to the nature of all
aldians but at the time this chapter
came out there wasn't enough information
to make it make sense after that it
referred to the scout as lady yamir and
bowed down as a sign of respect
something the members of the cult all
used to do when they were human
anyway the abnormal went through a range
of emotions during this interaction as
it tried to fight against the natural
urge to eat this scout literally tearing
away his own skin to suppress the
instinct sadly though in the end it
couldn't resist and ate the girl's head
as she documented the details of what
happened in her notebook this same
notebook was discovered by captain levi
a year later but before we get into that
it's worth noting that instead of eating
the rest of the body the abnormal buried
it inside a tree as another sign of
respect the area around this tree then
essentially became the titan's home as
the ova showed that it didn't like to
venture too far away from it and if it
did then it would try to run back there
as soon as possible hanji and a few
other scouts were able to follow this
abnormal all the way to the burial site
and in the process they also found the
notebook which documented everything the
titan had said
after reading the journal hanji became
aware that the name yamir had some sort
of relevance to the titans hence why in
season 2 she was incredibly shocked to
learn that one of the new scouts had
that same name last thing to mention on
the talking titan is that although its
fate was unknown in the original chapter
written by isayama the ova added this
extra scene in which levi cuts his name
next up in season 4 the wine that
contains zeke's spinal fluid had been
drunk by a lot of people including the
30 soldiers who were meant to be making
sure he didn't escape
as i explained earlier abnormals behave
or move in unique ways and through the
power of pars the beast item was able to
make abnormals specifically for the
forest environment whereas regular pure
titans either struggle to climb trees or
just straight up can't do it zeke
created ones that could easily climb and
swing between them at ridiculous speeds
when making titans zeke clearly has some
kind of ability to choose whether or not
to give them abnormal characteristics
because we all know that if those
soldiers have been turned into titans
the normal way you'd be lucky if even
one of them could climb trees following
this we have what is comfortably the
largest pure titan to ever exist and
that is of course the rod rice titan
according to armin it was double the
size of the colossal which makes it
around 120 meters tall and like certain
other abnormals its body proportions
just didn't make any sense if we zoom in
on this image here you can see that its
skinny chicken legs are not built to
support this super long torso and as a
result the titan couldn't actually stand
without holding onto the walls this is
why it literally crawled along the
ground instead of walking normally
resulting in its face being ripped off
because of the friction and its gross
titan organs obviously fell all over the
place for getting its massive size for a
second there are a few other things that
also make this titan super weird with
the first being the fact that it chose
to ignore nearby humans once the rampage
began rod never even attempted to eat
any of the people who were closest to
him but rather he preferred to crawl for
hours until he reached the highly
populated orville district that was
miles away on top of that the ryze
titan's body emitted a super hot steam
similar to what the colossal can do
hence why the trees began to catch fire
whenever he approached and why the
scouts had to douse themselves in cold
water
anyway it was implied by kenny ackerman
that the reason why it became so large
was due to him licking the time
transformation serum off the floor
instead of injecting it properly because
if you don't do it right then stuff like
this is a possibility
one other interesting thing about this
abnormal is that when his story adopted
the finishing bow to his nape she was
able to see certain memories from his
life ranging from his childhood all the
way till nearly the present day this is
a phenomenon that has never occurred
when other pure titans have been killed
but given that they're both of royal
blood we have to assume that that is
somehow the reason moving over to the
jumping titan now i actually love this
abnormal because the way it changed the
whole vibe of the episode it just
perfectly encapsulates what made early
attack on titan so amazing before the
jumping titan appeared the mood was
generally hopeful with aaron talking
about how quickly they could rise to the
ranks and thomas suggesting they should
do a challenge to see who could kill the
most titans the heroic background music
played is the sun shine down on these
guys but a second later the abnormal
titan appears the music stops and thomas
is eating alive while his friends can
only stand there and watch in less than
a few minutes we went from nervous
excitement to completely traumatized
while the abnormal then just got to walk
away like nothing happened much later on
the jumping titan was killed by aaron as
revenge with the attacked item biting
into its nape with full force and then
just throwing the body away
in season three there was a different
abnormal created by the malians and much
like wood rice its movement was severely
impaired by having legs that couldn't
support its weight the sad thing about
this particular titan is that it was
crawling for an unknown number of years
trying to reach the wall and at some
point it just gave up and gradually went
dead behind the eyes when approached by
the scouts it never once diverted its
eyes away from the ground showing that
even the presence of people was no
longer something that could awaken its
titan instincts or even its human
instincts it was just an empty shell
while the fate of this titan was never
revealed in my head there are two
realistic options either they put it out
of its misery on their return to the
walls or they left it there for years in
the hope that one day something would
turn it back into a human judging by how
aaron acted towards it in the anime and
considering that another titan was also
given the same treatment i'd say the
second option is a strong possibility
but let me know what you think in the
comments down below the next abnormals
appeared during the attack on utgard
castle in season 2 and even for
abnormals their behavior is virtually
unexplainable although both abnormals
were created by zeke that in itself
doesn't explain why they would attack
each other as you know he gains nothing
by making two of his creations fight
between themselves my purely speculative
guess is that these two might have
actually been young siblings back in
ragako village as the way they were
interacting kinda reminded me of kids
play fighting just on a larger and more
violent scale from what i remember this
was the first and only time that two
pure titans just randomly started
fighting without being given
instructions and you know them being
siblings it would make this make some
sort of sense but ultimately that is
just a theory
anyhow one thing i forgot to mention is
that technically speaking every single
titan zeke makes isn't abnormal even the
ones that seem normal since all of them
are able to function at night when the
moon is out this is something regular
pure titans can't do as they need
sunlight to operate whereas titans made
by the beast can move in both sunlight
and moonlight making all of them
abnormals by definition that being said
though some of them are clearly more
unpredictable than others with a notable
example being connie's mother who was
the second talking pure titan in the
series on connie's return to ragako this
titan famously said welcome home to her
son proving that she retains some
connection to her human consciousness
what was funny about this whole thing
was the way reiner definitely also heard
the titan speak but had to gas like cody
and make him seem like he was crazy for
hearing something that they both 100
heard the design of connie's mother's
titan was unique due to the exposed
ribcage and skinny limbs meaning it was
unable to move and was therefore left
alive in the village as it didn't really
present a threat to anyone other
especially weird abnormals made by zeke
include the posing titan the gymnast
titan and the butt ugly titan that had
his head partially exploded by the man
himself
during the 57th expedition beyond the
walls we saw a couple more abnormals not
made by the beast titan the first of
which was this freak who was resting
inside a derelict house it's no
exaggeration to say that this titan was
inches away from killing sasha and what
made it abnormal was the unique way its
legs allowed it to maneuver on all fours
this titan was eventually knocked out by
being led into a tree however because
the nate was never destroyed we can
assume it survived until presumably
being killed by the execution from hell
at some point a different titan then
appeared immediately afterwards and
besides walking like it has severe
constipation this abnormally ignored the
people around it in favor of heading
towards the center of the formation
while it was quickly dealt with by
experienced soldiers the celebrations
didn't last long because annie appeared
like a minute later and uh yeah we all
know what happens after that
flashing back to early that same season
mikasa killed an abnormal in trust that
was wildly sprinting towards the
innocent civilians and this was the
moment that inspired louise to become a
scout as well as being mikasa's very
first on-screen titan kill
in the clash of the titans jimmy pointed
out this abnormal here who was patiently
observing the four titan shifters in the
trees above it and i guess the thing
that makes him abnormal is his
intelligence unlike the other pure
titans around it it knew that it
couldn't climb the tree so instead it
casually laid down and focused his eyes
on them waiting for them to hopefully
make a mistake by that same standard i
guess this time here is abnormal too as
it was taking time to just stand still
and observe its targets instead of
immediately trying to eat them
technically speaking the dynafritz titan
is also abnormal if we consider that she
walked past berto without trying to kill
him although considering the full
context of the manga i think it's fair
to say that her usual behavior is that
of a regular titan
lastly as of recording this video the
final abnormal to appear in the attack
on titan anime is the war titan that was
discovered following the fight between
annie and aaron i plan to do a video
dedicated to the war titans in the not
too distant future so for this video all
i'll say is that if a pure titan is the
size of a freaking colossal then that is
enough to meet the abnormal criteria for
me
anyhow there were one or two random
titans in tross that i wasn't sure about
that might have been abnormal too but
for the most part i think we mentioned
everyone that's appeared in the series
if you enjoyed this video then be sure
to drop a like and hit that sub button
so you don't miss future content like
this and until the next one peace out